NARRATOR: The cannibal
sharks investigation
heads to Bimini in the Bahamas.
The mangrove swamps here
are a precious nursery
for lemon sharks.
Every year, scores
of pregnant females
return to these
shallow waters where
they were born to give birth.
But in a Machiavellian twist
that surprised scientists,
someone was eating the kids.
TRISTAN GUTTRIDGE:
Of 100 newborn sharks
born in June of one year,
by June the next year,
around 50 are left.
So 50% of the
cohort in every year
are eaten or die
from starvation.
NARRATOR: This pup is less
than two feet long, one
of a litter of up to 17 pups.
Scientists from the
Bimini Shark Lab
have been studying the lemons
here for more than 20 years.
They found the pups can
stay up to eight years
here, learning to
hunt and hide among
the twisted mangrove roots.
But the shock discovery
was the pups' biggest
threat comes from their own.
TRISTAN GUTTRIDGE: Everything
seems to kick off at high tide.
As the water rises,
it basically gives
access to shallow water
areas for big predators
to come in as well.
That's when these big
lemon sharks come in
and start patrolling and
cruising the outskirts
of those mangroves.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: The young
are on high alert.
They instinctively
hug the mangrove roots
which offer some protection.
But if they stray too
far, the hunt is on.
TRISTAN GUTTRIDGE: For a baby
lemon shark that's in close
proximity to a
big adult, if they
haven't seen it before it's seen
them, they've got no chance.
They can burst
attack very quickly
and ambush really effectively.
I've seen firsthand bite marks.
I've seen adults
chasing juveniles.
You know, we know
it's happening.
NARRATOR: It's clear evidence
shark cannibalism goes on
in the wild.
But why would you eat your own?
TRISTAN GUTTRIDGE: The
one great advantage
that an adult lemon shark has
is insider knowledge on where
the juveniles are
hiding and what
tactics they use
to avoid predators,
because it's been one itself.
And that gives it
an extra advantage,
and probably why they then
pick off the juveniles
of their own species.
What's happening here
in Bimini isn't unique.
Throughout the world
in other nursery areas,
big sharks are
eating little sharks.
It comes down to needing to eat.
Why would they not take
advantage of that resource?
NARRATOR: And now, new
research suggests this has
been happening for millennia.